and i love being an engineer it's it's
it's sherlock holmes and and being a
writer
at the same time it's it's like doing
stuff with
with your hands and creating stuff and
seeing it work
[Music]
gil tayar thank you for joining me how
are you good morning
good very happy to be here i i'm very
very happy to be here we've known each
other for quite some time
and you've been a very important part of
my personal journey both as
as a mentor throughout mentor and judge
throughout the different hackathons that
i organized but more importantly you've
introduced me
to uh to the whole world of developer
relations and and
and and advocacy for for
a great engineering and great coding and
and i've gained a lot of inspiration
seeing how much you enjoy the work that
you're doing and i
i don't i i speak to a lot of people and
i know a lot of engineers
i don't think i've yet to meet somebody
who's as excited
and enjoys their work as much as you
enjoy it
and so thank you so it's really
heartwarming also thank you for
for sharing that passion and i'd love to
focus these 20 minutes
both on that passion but more
importantly on on the world of
engineering and
knowledge sharing now just for context
there's i know that there's thought
leaders in a lot of industries right
there's
thought leaders in philosophy thought
leaders and economics
but you introduced me to the world that
there's thought leaders also in
engineering and
in good coding habits good engineering
styles and
and that's what i'd love to allude to
later on but first gill take me back
who are you and how do you become an
engineer yourself
ah first of all i'm like
i think the first wave of developers
that wanted to be developers in israel
and probably in the world
i started at the age of 13 and were
talking 84
83 so i was the dawn of the pcs
uh there weren't any pcs basically
before that
it was all mainframes and minicomputers
uh
at the age of 13 i got a zx81
from for the bar mitzvah um i'm not even
going to pretend that i know that
that i know what it is uh it's it's like
this little
little computer with chicklet keyboard
and it had 1k of of of ram
not one megabyte not one gigabyte and
not one k
and you could write little basic
programs and you connected it to your tv
okay there weren't any monitors and you
stored your
uh your programs on on a tape recorder
that that's the way it was and i learned
basic and i loved it and i
upgraded to 16k ram and everything
uh and decided this is what i want to do
you know for the rest of my life i got
an apple too afterwards blah blah blah
anyway long story short i ended up in
mamram
which is the com the um computer
it was the big computer unit uh in
in the israeli defense force it still is
uh very similar to uh 8200 um
one more time and uh back then much
much more known i did the whole training
nine months of computer
uh programming course and they wanted
and this is part of the devrel journey
in
a sense it's the start of it and they
wanted me to stay as a trainer
for computers uh for for the soldiers
and i said yes and and just understand i
was like this shy
not very talkative person but what i
found out was that
once i go up on a stage i
transform i transform into this like
sorry for the charismatic talkative
funny and everything speaker and and
and you know when i go back down out of
the state i
go back to being shy and fascinating
[Music]
why is fascinating obviously
slowly when i went back out of stage i
continued being that talk would have
been funny and
that's the girl that i know right
exactly
so in in a way that was the start of
changing myself and being more confident
with myself
and deborah and you know talking in
front of an audience
if you can you know if you can do it
gives you that
it gives you that confidence because you
go and you speak and and people and
people look at you and you know they
clap and it's a
it's it's an immense it gives you a lot
of confidence a lot of
a lot of uh um um
confidence 100 100 but so so you start
off so your deaf relations
journey starts off back in when you're
going and you're teaching and you're
training the next cohort of of engineers
in the army and and but you continue
doing that
throughout throughout your your entire
career right until today
you still go to many conferences every
year you go on stages now you do it over
zoom obviously
but besides that you you still chose to
be
a proper engineer a senior architect
right in in
in various startups and companies so
why so so first of all let's focus on
that why
be a senior architect what is it about
being an engineer that excites you that
you said okay
i want to continue being an engineer
because a lot of people that i know
at some point they said yeah we had i
had fun being an engineer now i want to
start managing teams
and i want to to go into the more
managerial scene
but you decided that you're still want
to be hands-on
and be an active part of the engineering
part of the company right
yes uh there's this tension once you get
good enough
uh the company wants you to uh
uh you know go up the ladder okay
and back then there was only one ladder
you become a team leader and then
you know a director and then a vp rnd
and
that's it and and
and i i tried that and i find that
i didn't like managing people i didn't
like
back then i didn't like being the one
responsible for what
they were writing right um you know
and i decided okay everybody wants me to
be
you know whatever but that's not what i
want
uh i want to code i'm i'm a farmer
i'm not a you know i want to till the
soil
i want to you know smell the the leaves
and figure out
what what's right for them uh and and
that is what i want and that is what i
wanted
and obviously being a good engineer i i
kept being pulled up
and and my career was like a seesaw it
was like
being pulled up to my injured population
and then saying oh no i don't want that
after a while i understood that [__] it
uh i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do that
anymore and whenever people say
you want to be a team leader i said just
no uh
i learned to say no and i love being an
engineer it's it's
it's sherlock holmes and and being a
writer at the same time it's it's like
doing stuff with with your hands and and
creating stuff and
seeing it work and not you know managing
the people that do that
and and i'm not disparaging i mean we
need both kinds of people
we need managers we need software
developers but you can have a career
that you know you can have a career that
goes the managerial way that forks to
managerial but today
it's called an individual contributor i
think uh you can
have a career that goes up the you know
more professional
uh technical water and and you know
the salaries are almost almost like 10
almost as high so don't worry about your
salary it will be high especially if
you're
good there i mean a good software
engineer
a great software engineer is worth their
weight in gold so
if you want to do that please continue
100 i know just
for that i it's coming by surprise as i
was going through my own journey within
the army and 8200 one of the things that
that was very interesting for us as
soldiers was that
people that are professional and they're
staying in the army let's say for five
six years
uh but and they're they're still
engineers they're still hands-on and
they make more money than somebody who's
an officer and who's leading a team of
people
and it was it and you know it was a big
dissonance because especially in the
army where
where you're a lot in a lot of places
your rank identifies your credibility
and
sort of your paycheck here you have a
unit that is one of the leading units
and the idea
probably in the world in terms of
engineering and it says whoa just
fyi if you're if you're a professional
and you're really really good you're
going to make even more than the
managers
which is which is very unorthodox and
it's very interesting
and i'd love to hear your take because a
lot of the people that are watching
this are not engineers and um you know i
i'm a huge advocate for studying
computer science i'm now studying it
hands-on and while
i may not be the most passionate guy in
the room about computer science
i am deeply passionate about problem
solving and the ability to problem solve
using the skills that we're gaining
so i'd love to hear from you why what
what is so attractive to you about
engineering
and perhaps maybe you know demystify
some of the some of the scary notions
behind what you might be doing on a
day-to-day basis
there there are two kinds of developers
um that that's
how i think about it uh
the developers that think that software
development is
in engineering and the people that think
that software development is a craft
it's it's you can immediately spot them
the engineers think that you know
we can get to perfect uh they love
type systems you know because they
believe that if you get the types right
everything will fall into place
and then there are the craftsmen they
understand that
nothing's perfect and software
development
is like oh it's like you know um
it's like voting in the us you can never
reach 100
for some reason it's always like a
tangent to perfect
and you can strive to that but it's
never that and you always have to mangle
it and fix it and deal with with you
know practical problems
i'm a craftsman uh and as a craftsman i
love to create
i don't see myself as really different
from uh
from a carpenter or from uh you know uh
somebody who makes dresses and and and
stuff like that
that i create using my tools which is
like the id and the keyboard and the
mouse
but what i create is as creative uh as
as as other craftsmen like you know
carpenters and whatnot
that is how i see it definitely there's
an engineering part of it i'm not
saying no but the way i see it as
craftsman and as a craftsman
almost an artsman almost an
artist that is the passion that i bring
to my work
craft right and i think that you know
that that is a great leeway to the
the notion of being the developer of
relations
and sharing your craft and sharing your
passion because
when you when you explain to me that
you're going up on stage and you're
bubbly and charismatic you're talking
about code
you're not talking about philosophy or
economics or politics you're talking
about
javascript often code behind you and
being charismatic about it and that is
something that i think
is going to be interesting for a lot of
people to hear because
it's very counterintuitive because up
until now you think of an engineer you
think of somebody who is a coder
they're sitting down in their own silo
and they're you know they're not really
you know human to human yet you're here
and you're breaking that paradigm
and then i encourage anybody to go and
look up guilty on youtube because you
you did
many of these talks first of all what is
developer relations
and then how does that fit into you know
this idea that there are
there are thought leaders in the
engineering world
so developer relations was used to be
called uh
evangelism and then it became developer
relations
and now it's developer advocacy but it's
basically a lot of things in one
one is if i'm a company if i'm in apple
tools right now
and uh we do developer tools so if we do
developer tools we need to market to
developers
and who's the best person to market to
developers well other developers like
myself
so one thing i do is we're dealing with
visual testing
so i talk about testing in general and
visual testing in conferences
and thus introduce people to apple tools
not as a marketing i don't
say a lot of appley tools i made demo
with apple tools but that's about it
but as oh okay there's this thing called
visual testing let's let's try it out
and
let's try it out with applications
that's one thing another thing is is
branding of the company i mean wix has
used it in israel very nicely
uh that is how i started the uh
developer advocacy
they don't care about developers in
terms of developer tools
but they want the best developers in
israel to come to wix and
one of the best ways to do that is to
create a
brand of wix engineering so that
developers will want to come to wix
because they hear
me speak or you know other developers
speak at wix
so that's the other side of developer
advocacy which is great for
other companies and the third is
we're a community um there's nothing
about i mean
especially oh you know open source it's
like everything's free everything's
community driven
and bringing giving back to the
community is part of what i do by
by educating by showing what i've
learned and
you know talking and and all that stuff
so those for me are the three
uh facets of developer advocacy and i
love
you know three of them how do ideas
spread
in the developer world so
in economics and physics it would be
through scientific papers
uh politics it would be through news how
do ideas spread
in the world of coding because some
often times
the things that i see that you're
talking about let's say visual testing
or why you should write tests for your
css i mean those are things that are not
necessarily mainstream
for a lot of organ organizations and yet
you're coming and you're
suggesting a paradigm shift or or a
breaking conception
that is not that easy so how how do
these new ideas become mainstream in our
world
uh just like memes uh um
it's a struggle between ideas out there
and and
the best idea wins in in in a way or
like the most um influential people that
bring the best ideas
they win and in essence and
and and credit is a lot about you not
just about you know
the ideas you you bring to the table um
credentials is going out there and
telling what you're doing it doesn't
matter if it's like new visual
like visual testing or if it's like
regular stuff like
when i talk about es modules in node.js
uh go out talk have people
see you do a lot of twitter don't do
facebook twitter is where the thought
leaders are
um do and you know
start start small don't don't try to go
to jsconf
right immediately which is like this
huge conference start with local meetups
uh get gain the confidence there and
gain the people there and then start
going up the ladder to you know
more international israeli conferences
and international conferences etc etc
uh credibility is is is it takes time
for me not like six seven years so
it takes time start small slowly grow up
talk about what you know it doesn't
really matter uh
you would believe you wouldn't believe
how much people are thirsty for
information
talk about what you know it'll be great
100 now your
your title is senior architect and
obviously that's
that's not a building architect it's
it's a different type of architecture
and how is that different from being an
engineer or a coder
what what is an architect in essence
uh my my sarcastic answer to that is an
architect is a coder
who's too old to be called a coder um
but but seriously it's it's not just
that
once you reach a certain level of of of
system
like of of a of a product uh where you
have
more code and it's not just you know one
server
one postgres one database and you know
rest api or whatever
once you need a system comprised of
microservices and message passing and
everything
you need somebody to figure out what
those
building blocks of that product is and
that's what a software arc
does uh basically i hate software
i call them architecture astronauts i
hate software architects that just
build you know the architecture and then
throw it the developers to code
that is totally wrong i build the
architecture along with other people
and then i just plunge in and write it
as we go along
understanding the problems with my
design as i go along and you know
changing it to fit whatever is needed
so for so for those listening that are
deeply passionate about
engineering and they see it they see
themselves as craftsmen just like
you see yourself and they're excited
about these but being that sherlock
holmes that you're both solving the
issue but you're also a novel writer
i i'll just i love that analogy and
what what some what tips can you give
from your experience
as they're going on their journey over
the years to become
better and more skillful
two things at least that come to mind
one
understand the technology
you're working at in a deep sense so
if you're using promises please
understand promises correctly
if you're using uh i don't know uh
functional programming
try and understand what functional
programming is about if you're using uh
kubernetes or docker how does docker
work
okay theoretically you don't need that
information
but practically in the real world you do
sometimes
and the more the deeper your
understanding is the more people will
you know come to you for advice and and
you can figure out the weird
problems so that's one deep
understanding of whatever you're doing
the second thing is over communicate
i don't say communicate i used to say
communicate but people you know when
over communicate say more than you think
that should be said
it's like when you're acting you're
supposed when you're smiling you're
supposed to smile
much more than regular so when you're
communicating do more than you what you
think you should be
and then you get to the right level of
communication
okay we problem solved gil why
under why over community why over
communicate and not communicate
because people tend to under communicate
so when you say to people over
communicate they give the right amount
of communication
also when you're explaining something
when you're talking about what you're
doing
the other side doesn't really understand
the context
so you have to explain and re-explain
and re-explain the context
and um and in that context along with
your explanation
that's how you get over it and
communication is crazy important
if you don't communicate then people
won't know how good you
are people won't know and and and vice
versa
and and i feel a lot when i over
communicate when i like
write right right and then i say hey
wait wait that that's wrong and then go
back to my software and fix it
a lot of times when i explain something
to somebody
i i figure out things myself so
talk talk talk write write write as much
as possible
gil i think that's that's that's such a
great insight because i think at the end
what you're saying about context is
crucial
we sometimes think for hours about a
problem
and we come up with our with our
resolution right and it could be you
know three bullet resolution
of what we think should happen and we
pre and that's the and we only provide
the outcome
but we sometimes neglect to provide the
whole thinking process
which explains the rationale behind the
solution and even if
the other person understands it they
might not accept it or they might not
even understand their solution without
the context of the thinking process
so that's definitely one of the most
important lessons that i'm taking with
me from this
girl i want to thank you for both the
inspiration these 20 minutes but
overall i think it's been maybe seven
years since uh
since we know we've been in contact so
so thank you for that and thank you for
for helping so many youth around israel
and the world through hackathons through
your journey
and obviously the countless people that
that are watching your
lectures and your presentations on
youtube and live
and but before we leave i have to ask
you for three words that you would use
to describe yourself
um fast uh
communicative and it didn't
really come out this time but funny
um lots of memes i can i can definitely
testify for that
gil thank you very much stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you